[Música]
caben abbassian muchas gracias por
aceptar esta entrevista para radio
canadá internacional cómo le va muy bien
grasos contrato verte
igualmente igualmente en esta casa vamos
a hablar de su última película que se
llama sin la habana está basada en la
historia del músico y poeta pablo
herrera 10 ya que está demasiado
proyectada en primicia en el festival de
nuevo cine de montreal este mes
virtualmente creo que podemos verla en
la sala no ahora no por el color verde
de quebec
si es una gran lástima porque me imagino
que para una primicia lo que uno quiere
es que la gente lo vea en una pantalla
grande entonces bueno pronto
en un día esperamos pronto
cabe en algunas notas de sus obras de
cine se ha interesado en lo que algunos
llaman el sur global si no me equivoco
he visto haití la india méxico ahora
cuba en varias de sus cintas que es lo
que es lo que le llama la atención de
estas realidades que son diferentes a
las de montreal donde usted vive y donde
usted nació creo
pero nadie notaba pero bueno creo que es
mi padre es decir a mí
a mí ya mi madre es de los estados
unidos y nunca me sentí qué
como en mi mundo totalmente en canadá y
la primera vez que me fui a méxico es
como bao es una otra manera de ver el
mundo y de
las relaciones entre gente y la comida y
entonces empecé a explorar un poco más
en seco dices en el sur global
y eso es bueno es una exploración que me
hay gente que aquí les gusta francia o
europa del este y para mí es más en el
sur me siento más cómodo hicimos
y justamente esta obra vamos a estar
viendo una serie de imágenes ahorita
sobre sobre esta esta película que su
primer corto mi perdón su primer
largometraje de ficción vamos a estar
viendo imágenes en esta historia usted
hay hay hay varios temas son temas muy
complejos ahí el tema de la inmigración
del racismo la misoginia por un momento
soledad el amor el arte choques
culturales hay un poco de todo en esta
historia a mí me gustaría saber por qué
quiso contarla esta en particular usted
conoce muchas historias me gustará
contado otro tipo de historias pero esta
en particular porque fue importante
contarla y esperemos que van a salir
algunas de las imágenes
bueno yo creo que es
la primera primera vez que me fuera a
cuba y qué
relaciones muy
bueno hay relaciones diferentes entre
turistas y locales que en otros países
es que hay mucho turismo de sexo y lo
que me estaciono es que
que es posible decir si este turismo de
sexo y nada más pero de hecho hay
hay vidas en esos tres mujeres y hay
amor de verdad
entre las personas
y es ese tipo de relación no sé cómo
hacerlo pero transa culo transaccional
23 que entonces no es malo y no es bueno
es es un área la realidad que vive mucha
gente en cuba y mucha gente que quiere
salir entonces eso es como lo que con lo
que me interesó al principio y también
bueno es una relación entre una iraní
canadiense y un cubano y por ello soy el
producto de un
de padres que son de diferentes culturas
entonces eso me interesa también como la
gente que
van a ver el mundo de maneras totalmente
diferentes cómo pueden vivir juntos o no
vivir juntos y cómo son esas relaciones
de esas expectaciones no sé si se dice
pero expectativas y expectativas lo
haces muy bien entiendo entiendo muy
bien porque además en canadá a pesar de
lo que uno puede creer no hay tantas
parejas mixtas ahí yo estuve viendo las
las cifras y tampoco es tan grande hay
parejas que se juntan por momentos pero
que no se quedan mucho tiempo juntos
entonces ver desarrollarse ese tipo de
yo lo vi en la película
hay una dinámica que se establece hay un
respeto y un amor y al mismo tiempo un
montón de dificultades alrededor de
estos choques culturales que se que se
ven que se ven reflejados en la historia
y por eso hablaba yo de complejidad
porque a veces es difícil entender
digamos como dos personas se pueden unir
en una en un contexto tan particular y
aún así respetarse y quererse tanto
finalmente entonces a mí me llamó mucho
la atención esa particularidad
y lo que me interesa también es que
puede haber mentiras entre dos personas
y al mismo tiempo tener amor entre los
mismos dos personas y la gente es mucho
más complicada que lo pensamos que una
persona no es malo bueno es que hay
muchas dios entre la gente
y muchos matices claro muchos matices y
así es la realidad también
yo creo que estamos en una época en la
que tenemos que recordar que los matices
son lo que lo que domina más que los
extremos cursos claro ahora es como
decíamos su primer largometraje de
ficción ya ha hecho varios cortometrajes
de ficción también y documental y
videoclips para grupos de música muy
conocidos por cierto pero hay algún
desafío particular al que usted se
enfrentó en este caso de hacer un
largometraje de ficción hay algo
específico que fue diferente de todas
las demás experiencias que tenía que ha
tenido
bueno hacer un largometraje es
totalmente diferente porque es como
empezamos a escribir la historia con
pablo herrera en 2004 ahora estamos 2020
entonces él es guardado y aquí me dio
con ese esa historia y el ser esa
el querer de hacer la película de hace
16 años entonces es como un parque y la
verdad es que el hecho que está
determinado ahora me siento como si hoy
no es súper contento que ya lo terminé y
que me gusta mucho la película y todo
eso pero es como un parte de mí no está
en mí es como parte de mi corazón ya
voló
y es por eso también que es tan triste
que no están ensaladas en este momento
porque después de todo este trabajo pues
que no quiero que la gente puede ver lo
que dice de verdad y no en un plato
si me imagino me imagino pero es un poco
como con los hijos que uno quisiera
dejarles cierto en camino y olvidada
agarrar otro camino quiero nunca previo
en ese sentido se parece las
experiencias siguen diría yo
totalmente
bueno tiene varios hijos en películas ya
es algo muy tiene mucha complejidad y
mucha mucha mucha vida en sí mismo cada
uno de esos proyectos
cabe otra pregunta que tenga con
respecto a los rituales porque parecen
ser algo que lo ha acompañado como decía
yo en varios de las diferentes de las
diferentes de los diferentes tipos de
cine que ha propuesto y parece que en
sus documentales e incluso en sus
películas de ficción siempre hay
rituales presentes y se ve en esta
película varios rituales
porque le interesan tanto los rituales
humanos lo que los seres humanos hacemos
para celebrar digamos momentos
específicos de la vida
sí yo creo que
sobre todo en el westin el óxido donde
vivimos por aquí hay una falta de
atención al nivel espiritual de la vida
no es que bueno yo no soy santero ni
youtube
pero
en firmando bien estudiando sus rituales
creo que bueno es como si hay una
montaña y todas las rituales son
diferentes en enteros para para ir en la
montaña y sin rituales es como casi no
puedes ni ver la montaña entonces eso es
lo que me interesa es como tener algo
que no es a esto he trazado para por el
metro que no tengo un ser al de la
dentista cosas así es como ver algo que
está
en alrededor todo el tiempo pero se les
es difícil verlo lo creo y es y también
es que quiero compartir esa esa visión
por el simple
y entiendo es un poco antropológica a su
manera de abordar el cine y finalmente
yo digo incluso las ficciones que he
visto
sí sí pero en mismo tiempo es como yo yo
yo me inicié a la santería también y es
como me voy a muy profundo en estos esos
rituales entonces lo que quiero hacer
con el cine es no tener como una afición
súper objetivo pero más de adentro
obviamente yo no soy cubano ni yo ni
haitiano
pero tampoco es tan lejos quiero ir a lo
más profundo que puedo y viven de quique
web de este punto de vista
claro entiendo cada vez yo creo que la
película va en cantarle a la gente
entonces con paciencia la van a poder
ver pronto en las salas por el momento
le deseo mucha suerte y le agradezco
mucho haber aceptado esta entrevista
para radio canadá internacional y que
todo salga más todo salga bien con él
con la promoción la distribución en la
presentación de la película a su placer
muchas gracias
[Música]